[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction le 78 lactu chaque soir du
lundi au vendredi voici tout de suite
les principaux titres de ce 17 septembre
qui seront développés au cours de la
prochaine demi-heure les violences de
juillet devant la justice versaillaise
appution ce mardi de deux jeunes hommes
soupçonnés d'être impliqués dans les
affroncements entre habitants et
policiers mais les deux procès des
hémetiers présumés ont été renvoyé à la
fin du mois d'octobre pas de
rapprochement avec villepr et plaisir
mais une intercommunalité plus large
c'est le souhait de Véronique coté
Millard mais rue d des clés sous boois
qui s'explique sur le chemin de l'école
un documentaire à découvrir le 25
septembre en France et dès ce soir à
l'UGC de montiné le bretonux a action
France soutient la diffusion de ce film
qui retrace le combat quotidien de
quatre enfants pour accéder à
l'éducation l'un des responsables de la
structure sera sur ce plateau pour nous
donner plus de détails à la fin de ce
journal l'image du jour et c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle en cette période
économique est difficile les journées
d'embauche du futur centre commercial
one nation Paris au clés sous-bois qui
début 800 personnes dont 80 % de
conseillers de vente et responsables de
boutique travailleront dans les 112
magasins dédiés au luxe à prix modéré
complexe de 24000 m² qui doit ouvrir en
novembre les candidats étaient donc
nombreux aujourd'hui pour décrocher un
emploi c'est à l'espace Philippe Noiré
qu'ils étit reçu aujourd'hui opération
qui se poursuit demain vous pouvez donc
encore vous y rendre avec vos CV
pourquoi ce recrutement en local la
réponse est donnée par la directrice de
one nation Paris au micro de Claire
Cambier d'abord parce que Madame le
Maire nous a fait confiance euh en voilà
en favorisant l'implantation de de one
nation Paris donc euh voilà c'est c'est
normal qu'on puisse aussi favoriser le
retour à emploi des personnes qui vivent
ici et puis aussi pour des raisons
extrêmement pratiques parce que Paris
c'est pas si près en transport en commun
donc c'est toujours plus pratique de de
pouvoir travailler à proximité de de de
son habitation ils ont 18 et 20 ans et
sont accusés d'avoir participé aux émeut
à trrappe durant le mois de juillet
dernier à la suite de l'interpellation
d'un homme qui aurait refusé le contrôle
d'identité de sa femme portant le voile
les policiers justement contestent eux
ce la les prévenus pardon contestent la
version des des policiers puisqu'il
parle de violence le procès devait
débuter aujourd'hui et premier coup
d'éclat ils ont été reportés à la fin du
mois d'octobre sur place pour la
rédaction les précisions de yolè Torz ce
matin ici à Versailles Majid dafel 18
ans et Alexandre Constanzo 20 ans
devaient être auditionné devant le
tribunal correctionnel les deux jeunes
sont soupçonnés d'avoir jeté des pierres
sur les policiers lors des émeutes de
trappe en juillet dernier ils sont
devant la justice pour Rebell et
violence l'affaire jugée trop complexe a
été renvoyée au 23 et 30 octobre
prochain les deux hommes sont
actuellement sous contrôle
judiciaire vendredi ce sera donc a tour
du mari de cette femme voilée dont le
contrôle avait déclenché les violences
d'être jugé toujours à Versailles les
villes doivent se constituer en
intercommunalité d'ici la fin de cette
année le schéma présenté par le préfet
n'est pas du goût de tous à l'instar de
la ville des clés sous-bois qui ne veut
pas d'une intercommunalité avec plaisir
et Villepreux trop petite trop coûteuse
estime la mèire véronique cotéillard qui
sollicite un cabinet d'avocat Catherine
zulato pour les
précisions avant la fin de l'année les
villes doivent se regrouper en
intercommunalité un dossier parfois
simple parfois épineux c'est le cas au
clés sous-bois la préfecture a arrêté
son schéma et a intégré la ville dans
une intercommunalité à trois communes
avec plaisir et Villepreux ce n'est pas
du goût du premier magistrat la ville
d'écla se trouve obligée c'est je pense
que c'est une première en France contre
contre sa volonté contre la volonté du
du conseil municipal de de rentrer dans
cette intercommunauté à trois communes
c'est pour ça que je m'y refuse c'est un
périmètre trop petit affirme Véronique
côé Millard l'élu udi s'appuie sur un
texte de loi en cours d'examen qui
stipule que demain la loi va inciter la
création d'intercommunalité pour des
bassins de 200000 habitants il faudra
donc totalement revoir la copie pour la
mer des clés sousbois c'est de l'argent
dépensé pour rien on nous demande d'ici
la fin de l'année de de créer une
structure à tro avec éventuellement des
transferts de de personnel et cetera et
il faudra dans le même temps la démonter
parce qu'elle va devenir obsolette avant
d'être d'être créé puisque cette
exigence de de commune d'intercommunauté
à
200000 nous sera imposé d'ici la fin de
l'année 2014 donc gros problème pour la
pour les habitants descla parce que
c'est une fiscal ça sera une fiscalité
additionnelle sans sans aucune
contrepartie et la le troisème problème
c'est un problème de gouvernance vous
savez que 3 c'est de contrains donc ça
c'est difficile ensuite de voilà de
pouvoir garder une certaine autonomie
sur les projets communaux pour la mer
des Clais sous boois la logique serait
de se tourner vers l'agglomération de
saanttin en Yveline la ville va saisir
un cabinet juridique pour attaquer cet
arrêté de périmètre intercommunal et
ainsi suivre les traces d'auberg enville
qui avait aussi déposé un référé contre
le schéma proposé par le préfet
dans et j'ajoute que le conseil
municipal de plaisir doit délibérer ce
jeudi soir autour de cette
intercommunalité la mèire de plaisir qui
a déjà prévenu son conseil municipal
elle souhaite voter positivement en
faveur de cette intercommunalité elle
organisera d'ailleurs une conférence de
presse lundi prochain en compagnie du
maire de Villepreux pour présenter leur
position commune vous aurez remarqué
l'absence de la mer des clés sousbois à
cette conférence de presse un dossier
qui est donc loin d'être clos après
l'intercommunalité de la métropole du
Grand Paris projet de loi présenté à
l'Assemblée nationale afin de donner vie
à ce nouvel ensemble c'était du durant
l'été nouvelle lecture prévue au Sénat
le 4 octobre l'Union des Maires des
Yvelines attend d'ici là des
modifications des amendements elle
craint une perte de son indépendance sur
la gestion des Transports du Logement de
l'aménagement du territoire nous avons
demandé au président de l'agglomération
de saintquanttin en nivelin ce qu'il
pensait de ce projet et si lui aussi
attendait des changements le nouveau
projet qui a été adopté à l'Assemblée
est un meilleur projet que le premier
voilà que deux éléments majeurs fait en
sorte que les de départements les plus
riches Paris et haut scène soit plus
étroitement lié à au valde Marne et à la
scène saint-enis me paraît une bonne
chose pour la solidarité et aussi pour
traiter les questions de logement sans
pour autant créer une strate de plus
dans notre millefeuille institutionnelle
voilà ça c'est bien après effectivement
autour de ce noyau fort de plus de 6
millions d'habitants il faudra des
intercommunités des pour le
métropolitain tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer de travailler ensemble sur un
système multipolaire c'est le sdrift qui
est un système multipolaire et et pour
nous notre système multipolaire Paris
saint-cly est un élément majeur de ce
système multipolaire de la région
Île-de-France 25 % de logements sociaux
pour les communes de plus de 1500
habitants qui appartiennent à une
communauté de communes de plus de 50000
habitants ce sera bientôt une obligation
et cela concerne également le monde
rural tout cela afin de répondre à la
pénurie de solutions d'hébergement
colère donc des élus concerné qui crent
une urbanisation mal maîtrisée colère
surtout de cinq petites communes du
département au Far Cernit la ville ou
encore bonelle qui verrai doubler leur
population et qui possèdent à ce jour
quasiment pas de logements sociaux nous
en avons parlé la semaine dernière sur
ce plateau avec Yv van Deval le
président du parc naturel de la Haute
Vallée de Chevreuse il a été reçu hier
pendant plus d'une heure au ministère de
l'Écologie de l'environnement il dit
avoir été entendu même s'il n'a reçu
aucune assurance de modification Yv van
Deval attend aujourd'hui d'obtenir un
entretien avec la ministre en charge du
dossier Cécile Duflot Montini va avoir
sa maison de retraite l'établissement
prendra place dans le château de La
Coudre cet ÉPA d'établissement
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes disposera de 84 lits les
travaux devraient à débuté début 2014
Anthony rche et Julien Leroi pour les
images la nouvelle maison de retraite
inimontaine sera divisé en deux parties
les services administratifs et sociaux
de l'épad seront installés dans le
château de La Coudre l'autre partie la
résidence service dédié aux personnes
plus autonomes sera construite à
l'entrée du parc l'établissement
disposera de 4 lit d'hébergement
permanent de 4 lit temporaires et d'un
pôle d'activité et de soins adaptés ces
aménagements devront toutefois prendre
en compte l'architecture du château il
va falloir aussi voir parce que les
pièces du château sont plus hautes que
aujourd'hui dans les habitats donc il y
a tout ce travail là il y a le
comblement derrière puisque derrière le
château actuellement c'est en creux donc
il va y avoir le comblement pour que
justement les jardins puissent être à
hauteur et que les personnes puissent en
bénéficier pour obtenir sa maison de
retraite la communauté d'agglomération
de 50 ans en Yveline avait déposé SEP
appels à projet seul la verrière et le
château de La Coudre Montini avait été
présélectionné finalement mi-juillet
Montini est choisi mais le permis de
construire doit encore être validé pour
la fin de l'année les pates devrait
ouvrir ses portes dès 2016 à noter que
le parc du château restera ouvert au
public deux autres projets ont été
retenus dans les ivelines à Montesson et
àofflet au total 300 nouveau l verront
le jour dans le
département
une nouvelle maison de retraite qui voit
le jour et justement il en a-t-il assez
pour répondre à cette demande qui ne
cesse de croître c'est notre question de
jour réponse avec ce micro trottoir
l'espérance de vie est de plus en plus
longue et il y a pas assez de place et
en plus le peu d'endroits qu'il y a
c'est très cher il y a peu de personnes
âgées qui pu qui ont les moyens de se
payer ce genre d'endroit en fait il en
manque quand même mais vous savez les
gens veulent plus rester chez que de
d'aller à la maison de retraite il y a
des résidences seniores qui sont de plus
en plus ouvertes mais ça va pas suffire
avec la population qui se qui vieillit
donc maison de retraite médicalisée faut
faire la différence entre les deux donc
résidence seior c'est tout à fait
différent et c'est selon les coûts c'est
pas du tout adapté à toute la population
et sinon en maison médicalisé et ben il
y a encore des choses à faire oh non
pourquoi parce que j' cherche une pour
ma mère et c'est pas facile ça dépend ce
qu'on définit par maison de retraite si
c'est des des maisons mourroires il y en
a trop par contre si c'est des maisons
genre enfin où les les les personnes
âgées sont bien accueillis bien entourés
où il y a un personnel suffisant où il y
a une un humanisme on va dire pour faire
une fin de vie sereine et agréable alors
là il il en manque les accidents de la
route sont la principale cause de la
mortalité des 1524 ans en France et on
pense bien sûr aux scooter ou encore aux
voitures mais il ne faut pas oublier les
incidents à bord des bus l'association
cahier de route avec des formateurs de
la société de transport scolaire ourtou
sont intervenus dans un collège de
plaisir en fin de semaine dernière
auprès d'élèves de 6e pour leur
apprendre les gestes de la sécurité
routière à bord d'un un autocar yolent
Torz Patrick Jacques de dixmud ceux du
côté couloir sortent au milieu face à
moi ils viennent de faire leur rentrée
au collège en classe de 6e et pour
certains le bus c'est leur tout nouveau
moyen de transport en commun un AG
sécurité routière leur apprend les bons
gestes en se basant sur ce que les
enfants ont déjà acquis on essaie de
faire un lien entre la voiture et
l'autocar le siège la ceinture de
sécurité l'accoudoir on leur présente un
petit peu le volume la taille du donc
c'est une grosse voiture pour eux donc
toujours par rapport à ce qu'il
connaissent en gros la limite c'est là
voilà les élèves ne doivent pas faire
demi-tour les élèves apprennent aussi à
évacuer au plus vite l'autocar en cas
d'extrême urgence il faut évacuer faut
faut écouter le chauffeur ceux qui sont
derrière ils passent par la porte de
derrière et ceux qui sont devant bah ils
passent devant en fait pas se précipiter
être calme avoir le sang froid sans
oublier le rôle primordial des
accompagnateurs ils apprennent notamment
à se placer aux endroits stratégiques
dans le bus l'association cahier de
route organise cet atelier de prévention
routière tous les ans pour les élèves de
6e de le on va le refaire une dernière
fois la nouvelle place de l'église à
guilloncour vient d'être finalement
inauguré les habitants et les
commerçants l'auront attendu pendant de
longs mois les travaux avaient dû être
arrêtés après la découverte d'osement
datant de l'époque merovinggienne
Catherine zulato et Michael
Jarry la place de l'église à guyancour
n'a certes pas été rebaptisée elle
existait déjà mais pas sous cette forme
une place donc remanié même doublement
remanié car si l'idée du départ était
d'avoir un parvis de plein pied le
sous-sol on a décidé autrement en cours
de travaux il y a eu des fouilles
archéologiques qui ont montré que nous
avions sous les terres de du parvie un
ancien cimetière donc il s'agissait à ce
moment-làah de préserver ce caractère
archéologique et de réaliser quand même
le projet donc on a modifié le projet on
est tombé sur des vestiges
movingien donc c'està-dire que c'était
vraiment quelque chose qui avait de la
valeur interdiction absolue de venir
creuser le sol existant on a donc remis
en question complètement le projet
initial qui était du même niveau que la
placette au niveau de la pharmacie et de
la voie pour concevoir cette fois-ci un
parvis qui soit en surélévation par
rapport au vestige
identifié le chantier a été repoussé de
8 mois pour un résultat qui mèle
différents matériaux tout en pierre
calcaire pour le parvie de la meulière
pour les jardinières et les pavés gris
pour souligner les marches les travaux
auront finale coûtait 877000 € avec une
participation de la ville de guillancour
à hauteur de 500000 € et le reste par la
Communauté
d'Agglomération le parc du poirier
Saint-Martin a été inauguré lui aussi à
Montini le Bretonneux un parc avec des
équipements de loisirs mais pas
uniquement un lieu d'apprentissage
écologique avec notamment une marre
éducative ou encore un refuge pour les
oiseaux un reportage d'Olivier Manis
calco et de Jonathan
villman inauguration du nouveau parc du
poirier Saint-Martin le Bretonneux
malgré la pluie une petite centaine de
personnes s'est déplacé pour l'événement
outre la découverte des terrains
sportifs et des jeux pour enfants
l'occasion était aussi de présenter la
qualité environnementale du parc déjà
abondante avant la rénovation des lieux
la nature et la biodiversité ont fait
partie des priorités architecturales
lors des travaux une marre pédagogique
alimentée naturellement accueille
d'ailleurs ses premiers insectes et
libellule dém et des projets comme ça il
en existe il en existe un petit peu
partout là l'intérêt c'est que c'est en
cœur de ville c'est la source de la vie
on est sorti de l'eau donc je trouve que
dans un projet écologique la présence de
l'eau était importante ça permet de
sensibiliser les les enfants à la nature
à la création de la vie ils vont venir
avec les les enseignants la vie
s'installe ça fait à peine 2 mois que
Laam est installée et est pleine alors
il y a déjà de la vie par que quand on
s'approche on voit ça grouille il y a
des bulles on voit des petits
insectes sous la surface de l'eau sur la
surface de l'eau et
dernièrement j'ai appris qu'une
grenouille était présente déjà sur le
site et elle est venue apparemment
naturellement au côté de la mar un
refuge à oiseau installé par la LPO voit
ses premiers habitants arrivés le jardin
pédagogique va permettre à terme un
diagnostic et un suivi écologique de la
faune et la flore présent à Montini le
Bretonneux invité à présent de cette
édition mafououf bonsoir bienvenue sur
ce plateau vous êtes responsable de la
mission éducative d'Aide et Action
France ce soir avant-première l'UGC de
Montini le Bretonneux du documentaire
sur le chemin de l'école qui sortira en
France dans une petite semaine le 25
septembre votre association soutient
selon métrage il est question de
scolarité de ce combat pour accéder à
l'éducation dans de nombreux pays du
monde vous pouvez pour commencer nous en
dire plus sur l'histoire de ce film ou
plutôt les histoires parce qu'on suit
quatre enfants quatre jeunes euh merci
de m' vooir invité donc sur ce plateau
pour parler un peu du film le chemin sur
le chemin de l'école donc qui est une
œuvre extraordinaire parce que c'est un
film qui retrace l'histoire de quatre
jeunes enfants donc dans quatre coins du
monde en Argentine euh au Maroc en Inde
et au kan donc il s'agit euh d'illustrer
aujourd'hui euh les difficultés que des
jeunes donc euh qui veulent accéder au
savoir rencontre h donc à travers ces
pays-là euh ce film et action est
partenaire de ce filmlà parce que euh
donc l'une des histoire euh celle du
Maroc notamment a été donc tournée euh
dans l'une de zone d'intervention c'est
l'histoire de Zaira 12 l'histtoire de
Zaira 12 ans donc qui est une jeune
Marocaine et qui euh donc euh parcours
donc plusieurs kilomètres pour aller
toutes les semaines à l'école parce que
Zaira quitte son village une fois pour
une fois par semaine pour aller donc à
Asni le la la commune donc chef-liu donc
de ce de ce canton là et qui passe à
l'internant donc euh tout une semaine
des histoires extraordinaires ce sont
des enfants qui parcourent plusieurs
kilomètres pour pouvoir accéder à
l'éducation l'éducation c'est un droit
difficile à obtenir c'est un droit
difficile à obtenir et le film montre
tous les défis h auquel la communauté
internationale est confrontée parce que
si on parle d'accès à l'éducation pour
tous on se rend compte aujourd'hui les
limites de l'accès à l'éducation dans la
mesure où on a encore dans certains coin
reculé du monde où les enfants ont du
mal euh à avoir les conditions en tout
cas idouines pour aller à l'école parce
que là où un jeune doit faire 12 km ou
15 km pour aller à l'école avant déjà de
pouvoir s'investir euh donc dans le
travail scolaire euh vous comprendrez
que c'est tout à fait difficile alors on
évoque les rythme scolaire en France
effectivement il y a d'autres
problématiques dans dans dans les autres
pays vous avez cité Zaira puisqueil y a
des actions intervient direct ement au
Maroc on peut aussi citer Carlos que
vous découvrirez dans le documentaire
qui est projeté ce soir en
avant-première à l'UGC aux alentours de
20h 20h30 on va en reparler puisque le
film sortira ensuite pour tout le public
à travers la France le 25 septembre
histoire de Carlos 11 ans lui il
traverse les plaines de Patagonie sur
plus de 18 km avec sa petite sœur deux
fois par jour quel que soit le temps
tout à fait et là c'est c'est c'est
c'est une histoire à la fois émouvante
et je pense que l'histoire de ces jeunes
là c'est en quelque sorte une leçon de
vie h pour à la fois les adultes mais
aussi les jeunes enfants les jeunes de
leur âge donc qui ont peut-être moins de
difficultés en tout cas à accéder à à
l'éducation et que le film traite
plusieurs sujets parce qu'on a l'accès à
l'éducation mais au-delà de l'accès à
l'éducation il y a aussi tout le combat
de l'éducation des filles parce que la
petite fille déjà vous voyez tout toute
la difficulté donc qu'elle rencontre
avec son frère sur
de cheval pour aller à l'école vous
voyez Samuel donc qui qui qui traîne un
handicap qui malgré tout cela ne
l'empêche pas de rêver ne l'empêche pas
d'aller à l'école donc on a vraiment des
histoires émouvantes des histoires qui
nous qui nous qui nous qui nous donnent
un peu euh qui nous donnent envie d'agir
encore davantage parce que c'est vrai
que nous faisons beaucoup de choses
quand je dis nous je dis diretion je je
parle de la communauté internationale
mais il y a encore beaucoup d'efforts à
faire pour arriver à ce que tous les
enfants puissent avoir les conditions
idéales tout du moins les conditions
minimales pour pouvoir accéder à à à
l'éducation et des actions qui
intervient qui soutient ce film qui est
partenaire de de ce film avant-première
ce soir à l'UGC de montinil Bretonneux
entre 4 et 10 € pour y accéder il
fallait s'inscrire auparavant sur le
site internet qui s'affiche à l'écran il
est peut-être un petit peu tard pour
vous y rendre mais ceux qui veulent
véritablement découvrir le film le
documentaire dès ce soir sachant que
l'argent sera versé à Aide et Action
hein c'est l'objectif de cette
avant-première ils peuvent encore s'y
rendre oui ils peuvent s'y rendre donc
il y a la possibilité pour ceux qui
n'avaient pas réservé des des des compes
marques de pouvoir acheter sur place
donc des des Liers pour entrer et vous
pouvez vous rendre dès ce soir donc à
l'avant-première je vrais qu'on sur le
travail d' d'IDE et action qui
intervient depuis 1981 pour permettre
l'éducation de tous action développée
par 452 salariés des milliers de
bénévoles dans le monde 2012 a action a
mis en œuvre 119 projets dans 25 pays
quels sont les types de projets
concrètement que vous développez sur le
terrain avec a et action alors a action
développe plusieurs types de projets
parce que nous avons des projets qui
sont axés sur l'éducation des filles et
des femmes euh parce que comme vous le
savez l'éducation des filles est un
enjeu aujourd'hui dans dans certains
pays du Sud notamment où l'accès à
l'éducation des filles est assez
compliqué pour plusieurs raisons il y a
aussi tout le travail sur l'amélioration
de la qualité parce que une chose est
d'envoyer les enfants à l'école mais il
va falloir aussi que ces enfants-là
puissent acquérir des savoirs et des
compétences compétences de base qui leur
permettent de pouvoir demain être utile
à leur société donc à ce niveau nous
intervenons donc sur la formation des
enseignants nous intervenons sur tous
les aspects qui peuvent concourir à
améliorer les conditions d'apprentissage
mais aussi améliorer l'environnement des
apprentissages parce qu'il faut non
seulement améliorer les conditions mais
aussi l'environnement des apprentissages
euh nous avons aussi des projets sur la
formation professionnelle des jeunes
parce qu'en fait c'est un des enjeux
aujourd'hui des enjeux euh dans tous les
contextes la question de l'emploi des
jeunes se pose avec acuité et là aussi
nous avons développé en Inde par exemple
une initiative très intéressante qui euh
qui qui qui qui met l'accent sur les
compétences sociales et professionnelles
pour permettre à ces jeunes-là non
seulement de s'insérer sur le plan
économique mais au-delà aussi d'être des
citoyens engagés pour le développement
de la localité une trentaine d'années
d'action de combat qui ont été mené par
Aide et Action pour autant les chiffres
restent édifiants 57 millions d'enfants
d'âge d'aller à l'école primaire nonont
pas accès à l'école plus d'un milliard
de personnes dans le monde vivent avec
l'extrême pauvreté ça complique d'autant
plus l'accès à l'école est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment d'avoir aussi réussi à
endiguer un petit peu ces ces très
mauvais chiffres ces très mauvais
résultats est-ce que vous obtenez des
résult concret est-ce que vous êtes
satisfait de l'action qui est mené sur
le terrain oui euh je pense qu'il y a
encore des efforts à faire mais il faut
quand même signaler qu'il y a
d'importants efforts qui ont été
réalisés ces dernières années parce que
il faut rappeler que il y a de cela 10
ans en arrière l' l'accès à l'éducation
était le taux en tout cas d'accès à
l'éducation notamment dans dans beaucoup
de pays en Afrique et peut-être en Inde
était très bas aujourd'hui quand même
nous sommes arrivés à un niveau où euh
des où où les taux avoisine 80 90 % il y
a encore euh 10 à 15 % euh d'enfants qui
n'arrivent pas à à à accéder à
l'éducation mais euh je pense que
l'effort des ONG notamment et des
actions depuis 30 ans où nous sommes
inter les terrains où nous sommes
intervenus nous avons quand
même noté des efforts considérables euh
il y a au aujourd'hui une tendance très
favorable notamment sur l'éducation des
filles il y a des zones où aujourd'hui
euh on a 52 52 % de filles qui sont qui
sont à l'école dans certains pays alors
qu'il y a 10 ans de cela c'était un
écart c'était un rapport peut-être 40 60
donc c'est un résultat concret qui a
obtenu sur le terrain grâce notamment à
Aide et Action et si vous voulez voir
concrètement les difficultés rencontrées
par les enfants par ses enfants à
travers le le monde entier pour accéder
à l'éducation il y a ce documentaire sur
le chemin de l'école on regarde juste le
début de de la
[Musique]
bandeannonce
bismirmanirim sur le chemin de l'école
c'est donc ce documentaire à découvrir
en avant-première ce soir à Montini et
le bretonux à l'UGC vous pouvez
directement vous y rendre c'est entre 4
et 10 € pour le prix des places et c'est
reversé à l'association Aide et Action
qui est partenaire mafououf le
responsable de la mission éducative
d'Aide et Action France était avec nous
ce soir juste avant de vous rendre à la
projection merci à vous c'est la fin de
ce journal je vous retrouve demain des
18h en direct pour un nouveau point sur
l'actualité locale et puis également
cette semaine à noter nouveau
rendez-vous de municipal 2014
rendez-vous politique de la rédaction de
TVF diffusion le mardi 18h30 19h30 et
23h le replay comme d'habitude sur notre
site internet excellente soirée à
[Musique]
demain